good afternoon cs109 how are you guys
doing
fantastic
um hey welcome back from the break I
hope you guys had a wonderful
Thanksgiving I hope you had a chance for
some rest some relaxation uh possibly
some good food and some family time uh
and it's really wonderful to see you I
of course in the holiday spirit took
some time to think about the things I'm
grateful for and how lucky am I to be
here doing the job that I love the most
which is teaching with such a wonderful
group I am getting a little sad that
we're getting close to the end of the
quarter I'm like ah I will miss you guys
anyways that's that's not what's
important right now
okay
it's been a while so I thought it'd be
nice to just take a moment and recap
where we left off before we jump into
today's great topic
in cs1 I'm wearing this final part of
the class where we're learning about
machine learning it is going to take us
to the point where we're going to learn
how deep learning AKA neural networks
work but in order to understand that you
need to know the most core
classification algorithms naive base and
logistic regression and those two
algorithms like all of deep learning
rest upon a foundation of parameter
estimation if you have any probabilistic
model how could you estimate the numbers
that could make the probabilistic model
accurate or inaccurate
machine learning when we talk about it
in cs109 it's generally a pretty simple
process this is the process of you're
going to be building a model which we
sometimes think about as these black box
models where somebody could give you
inputs features for a particular
individual your black boss module will
do some work and it'll come up with a
prediction and the work that the Black
Box module does will be based on some
numbers some key numbers that we call
parameters and a lot of work and machine
learning is setting these parameters so
that your black box is able to make good
predictions
particularly in cs109 we've been talking
about a specific prediction type called
classification and classification is
where you're not just predicting
anything you're predicting discrete
class labels like for example one or
zero will somebody have a healthy heart
one or zero will somebody like a movie
or one or zero somebody coming from a
particular ancestry
the most interesting part of machine
learning comes in what we call training
so in the first step you formalize a
problem you take a real world problem
you make a model you come up with a
formal model that has parameters but the
interesting thing is when you take data
and use those datas to learn the
parameters
uh the once you've done that though it
is worth noting that it is beholden upon
you to try and estimate how good your
algorithm is so we will reserve some
data for testing and then we can say
we've got an algorithm it's trained and
this is how accurate we think it is
training data awesome it has this crazy
notation in order to gain intelligence
for classification tasks I'm going to
give you a bunch of data we call that
data training data and training data is
going to be a combination of features
and you're going to be told the label
for this particular individual so you
say in my training data here's one
individual they've got these features
and a one or zero for their class label
this is generic it works regardless of
what problem you're talking about but it
does have some notation I don't want to
lose people on this superscript is
saying which individual we're talking
about the X are the inputs aka the
features and the Y's are the labels m is
the size of the features so how many
inputs do I have per individual I found
that notation quite hard so I spent a
little time in class making sure that we
understood uh what that notation was and
particularly you know if you have an
individual we think of the X's as being
the list of numbers for the inputs and
they'll be m of those and the why being
the prediction of healthier not healthy
in training data you're told both X and
Y and the real interesting thing is to
build a machine where you could just put
in inputs and it would predict the why
okay maybe questions about you know this
general idea of classification before we
jump into the one algorithm we've got so
far naive Bayes
well just before the break we talked
about an algorithm how you could do
classification we said okay if you want
to build this black box we're just going
to take some inputs and make a
prediction one way you could do that
is you could make a little probabilistic
model and that probabilistic model is
going to be able to compute what's the
probability that y equals one given X
and the probability that y equals zero
given X and then we're either going to
choose our prediction to be one or zero
classification has to give back one over
zero based on this probability very
reasonable thing to do
and particularly you know imagine this
if you have this probability we'll try y
equals zero and we'll try y equals one
and whichever one is the larger value
that's the prediction we'll make that's
why this ARG Max exists just so we can
turn a probability into either a zero or
a one
naive Bayes though while this was a nice
idea didn't work we couldn't make a
probabilistic model that would generally
work so we made this awfully incorrect
but very helpful assumption that the
probability for any individual
of their inputs given their output is
equal to the probability of each input
on its own given the output so this is a
whole Vector of numbers so it's the
probability of X1 and X2 and X3 and X4
given y we're going to say that's going
to be the product of each feature we
assume the features are independent of
each other given the class label
now this was the derivation and the
naive Bayes assumption shows up right
here but importantly you know if you
make this assumption then you end up
with a way to make your prediction we
use log probabilities because numerical
making sure it works on the computer is
very important and the product a bunch
of probabilities could become quite
small
and you know we do this derivation it
leads to this very simple way of how we
can make our predictions
all these things are learnable you are
now tasked with based on your training
data learning this probability the
probability that y equals zero and then
probably that y equals one
you also have to learn each of these
probabilities for every feature what's
the probability that each feature takes
on its value given y equals either zero
or one
those are all very very doable things
particularly if you want to learn each
of these things is just going to be
counting mle says these are Bernoulli's
so we can estimate these Bernoulli's
base the probability P of these
Bernoulli's just counting
then we went really deep into this map
this Bayesian way of parameter
estimation and it just ended up if you
had a LaPlace plier of being counting
with a little bit of addition
so long story short we have an algorithm
it's called naive Bayes it uses this
awful assumption but it turns things
into just counting so training just
becomes counting and then predictions
just require you to put your counting
through the particular function that we
derived
so at this point we have an algorithm
which is fantastic
but there are other algorithms it turns
out there's other outcomes saying you
absolutely should know because some of
these other algorithms have changed the
way that the whole world works of
artificial intelligence
and we're going to learn about that
today but a little bit more background
that's worth recalling
is optimization
when we were talking about parameter
estimation one of the great ideas that
we came up with was if you want to find
parameters that maximize likelihood
you're actually doing an optimization
task you're saying I'm going to want you
to choose parameters for me and I want
those parameters to be such that the
likelihood is as large as possible and
we figured out that this was kind of
like an optimization task and in order
to do that we said you know we can use
hill climbing particularly we could use
gradient ascent and gradient scent tells
you that if you can give me the
derivative of the thing you care about
with respect to each of your movable
dials if you give me those derivatives
then I've got a very simple algorithm to
come up with very good parameters so a
little bit of recall gradient ascent
gradient and scent gradient descent are
brother and sister algorithms one could
just be optimizing the negative of the
other and just to recall you have a way
of optimizing parameters for a
likelihood function and is gradient
ascent
okay
so this wasn't that important okay and
review
that was a lot but feel free to ask
questions if you forgot something and
you want me to recall it this is
supposed to be a conversation in fact
what you're learning today you're going
to have to program in your problem sets
and it's something crazy important for
the world so I want you guys to
understand it deeply I would like to
invite you to ask the questions you're
curious about because other people in
class will be curious about it as well
it's time one of my favorite things to
teach logistic regression a very simple
algorithm for making a classification
prediction
that is going to be very impactful
because it is in fact the heart and soul
of deep learning if you've heard of
neural networks or deep learning it is a
bunch of logistic regressions put on top
of each other so learn logistic
regression it is critically important in
order to understand logistic regression
we are going to be taking advantage of
some of the parameter estimation we've
seen so far
I know I just gave you a lot of review
I'm just gonna give you a tiny bit more
mathematical background because I don't
want to lose people on some
prerequisites that you might not have
seen before well this is less of a
prerequisite but it's just more of a
cool thing to know
there is this function that people in AI
love it's called the sigmoid function
which is so confusing why is it so
confusing because we've seen sigmoids
before when have you seen sigmoids
yeah the variance of say like a normal
distribution hey you guys it's an
interesting day
before pandemic I had this policy of
bringing fruit to class and if people
ask questions if they're interacted I
would give out fruits and then you know
the whole world stopped with covid and
you couldn't through like fruits through
Zoom so I stopped and then we came back
but you know
just giving fruits didn't feel right
when we were all so worried
um but I have fruits again for the first
time in like three years this is a
special day so anyways ask a question
get a little Mandarin you can eat after
class share with your friends as you
like anyways
as we last left off sigmoid is a
confusing name because it means a very
different thing this symbol is also used
for variants the sigmoid function is a
totally different thing the sigmoid
function is just a way of writing this
whole piece of math in a condensed way
and this whole piece of math is saying
take some input
and take one divided by 1 plus e to the
power of negative that input if you were
to graph it for all the different
possible inputs it looks like this
and people in Ai and probability love
this function for two reasons
one reason is it's a squashing function
no matter what number you put into this
your output will be between zero and one
and I don't want to give things away but
people in probability love that because
if you can guarantee that your output's
between zero and one then it starts to
look like something that maybe you could
call a probability
anyways this is just a function you
should know we haven't used it for
anything too deep I have written the
function itself over here on the board
uh caution not the same Sigma that you
learned about when you're a weak kid in
the first half of cs109
our background before we jump into
things is some key notation
you've probably seen this in like math
51 or something like that before which
is the transpose of two vectors if Theta
is a vector and X is a vector and
they're of the same length Theta
transpose X is another way of writing
this sum it's saying take the first
element of both of these vectors
multiply them together then add that to
the product of the second element and
add that to the product or the third
element and the product of the nth
element
so this
is really what that is saying but you
can imagine these three are three
different pieces of notation for writing
the exact same thing it is saying in
element wise product and then the sum
over the sum over the element wise
product
again I wrote that over here you know
Theta transpose X is this sum you'll
notice on the board I actually have this
starting at zero not one it depends how
you index your list but I'm going to
start indexing by zero in a little bit
which you'll see when we get there any
questions on this notation don't get
lost on Note
would you want to get lost in background
anything confusing or what is confusing
about this
just want a mandarin anybody just want a
mandarin yeah I just want to make sure I
clarify is the is Theta a matrix or a
vector it's going to be a vector so if
Theta is a vector and X is a vector so X
could be like for example this is
generally true if x is a vector but
maybe it could be a list of features
okay and we're going to try something
because I'm afraid of breaking a camera
we're going to pass this back okay
fantastic
now if you want to be super fancy
when you do this you end up with this
big calculation but if you were to
actually get a computer out and evaluate
this this would be a number
and because this is a number you can put
it into that function
so you can take this calculation take
the number that results and put it
through the sigmoid notationally if you
did that you could say that's the
sigmoid of theta transpose X which would
be the same as a sigmoid as that or the
sigmoid of that these are three
different ways of writing the same thing
or you could just put that number into
the sigmoid itself
notation but that's just
into any point of our derivations okay
so background I put on the board keep it
in mind and if you have questions later
ask me
oh the chain rule man I remember when I
learned this in math and it wasn't
motivated at all we're like just going
to learn calculus and because we're
learning calculus you needed to know the
chain rule so you could do the things
that were on the final I wish my math
teacher had told me this was the idea
that would mathematically change the
world like the chain rule is the reason
that we can stack things that are
derivable on top of each other and have
neural networks learn through the whole
thing because computers can do the chain
rule it's crazy important but anyways
the chain rule says you know if you have
some function and you can decompose it
uh you could say if f of x you want to
drive it with respect to X if you can
decompose this into saying like f is
actually some other function Z of X you
can do F of Z with respect to Z
so you know reference how this function
changes with respect to its input and
then derive F of Z or Z with respect to
X
just want to recall this but I think if
you haven't seen chain rule a please do
watch your favorite Khan Academy video
on the Chain Rule and second I will show
you it in action and you should
particularly make sure you understand
chain rule in the context I talk about
it today's class
okay I'm so excited we've done our hard
work we've done a review we've done our
background it's time to have a big party
and learn about logistic regression
chapter one the big picture
we want to invent the next
classification algorithm
and classification you're gonna be
building a machine where you put in
inputs and it makes a prediction and we
decided that a really good way to build
this machine would be if we could
calculate the probability of the output
taking on the value 1 or 0 given the
inputs if we could know that conditional
probability we could make a really great
machine
naive Bayes tried to do this and in
order to do this it made this really big
assumption you know the probability of
each feature given y being the product
of each feature on its own given y
it's helpful it made the math really
simple but it's definitely wrong in some
cases it's not always true that the
features would be independent of each
other given the output
but the simple idea that is going to
drive all of today is a bit of a light
bulb moment
what if we just allow this to be a bit
more of a machine that we construct what
if we just build a machine that could
directly figure out the probability of Y
given X
and that was the simple light bulb idea
that lentil logistic regression
the simple idea was okay we've got our
X's that's going to be a list of ones
and zeros
we have to predict our y That's either
going to be a one or a zero
and the simple idea of logistic
regression is well what if we're just
constructed a machine that took those
x's and predicted Y and we allowed that
machine to be you know a little bit more
flexible than say something that had to
be a naive Bayes model
and particularly people started using
this one specific machine they said okay
I'm going to build a machine where I'm
going to take each of these numbers
my machine is going to have a weight for
each number I'm going to weight each
number
sum them all up sum up all those
weighted things and then I'm going to
get a number which I'll squash and I'm
going to call the squash thing the
probability that y equals 1.
craziness let me give you that picture
in a little more detail logistic
regression assumption is I'm just going
to build you a machine that's got some
parameters in it that are movable
you're going to choose great values of
parameters such that your machine
when it takes in X's just outputs things
that are close to the probability that y
equals one
given those particular inputs
here I I think this machine is so
important to understand it's one of the
most important machineries to get your
head around so I spent some time trying
to make this machine look a little
prettier than just that equation
people said okay you're going to take
your inputs and you're going to predict
whether or not y equals one so you want
the probability that y equals one given
your inputs we're gonna have a
probability producing machine
take all your inputs and every input is
going to go through this channel where
it gets weighted it's going to be
weighted by parameters
and then every channel once it gets
weighted is going to come into big
summation unit we're going to weight
each Channel and then sum them together
you could call this sum Z if you wanted
now when you take in inputs and you
weight them and you sum them together
there's no guarantee that this looks
anything like a probability
so then what we're going to do is we're
going to put it through a squashing
function and this squashing function
will take this number and make it look
like a probability and then the craziest
thing is we're going to interpret that
as the probability that y equals 1.
craziness I use this metaphor of a
soundboard where each of your parameters
are movable dials and you can move them
to change the thetas and that would
change how your machine works
okay in my cartoon just to be clear
these are the inputs you know you could
have a everything you're making
prediction of will come with a list of
inputs and we're just going to set the
machine to start out with whatever those
inputs are if we're making a prediction
for example if you're predicting whether
or not somebody likes a movie the inputs
could be yes or no did they like other
movies
the output is also in this case going to
be a one or a zero and it's going to be
yes or no do they like the target movie
and we would like it so that this
machine when you take an individual and
you set whether or not they like these
three different movies once it's
weighted those ones and zeros sum them
up put it through its quashing function
we would like the probability that comes
out to be as close as possible to the
true probability that this individual
would like that movie
can I be clear about something
is this how the world really works is
there something true about the universe
like when probabilities are being
produced it actually underneath the hood
the universe is making this little
machine and you know pushing Pro these
inputs through these weights and then
squashing it
no there's nothing realistic about this
it's wrong why would we use a wrong
model
because it turns out this wrong model is
very useful so we're going to make this
little machine and the most beautiful
thing about this machine is it's going
to end up being a Lego block and we'll
be able to stack them on top of each
other but I'm getting ahead of myself
yes question
I'm proud good question I haven't told
you yet but it's going to be really
important if I put random thetas I've
got a random machine but my claim for
you is if some you know oracle came and
gave you the best setting of thetas then
maybe this could be pretty reasonable
but your question is where did they come
from
it's going to come from parameter
estimation but but I haven't told you
that don't you know here you go
okay question question uh
[Music]
so yeah this washing function is going
to give you a number between zero and
one and yeah we are going to say like if
it gives you a value of 0.8 we're going
to assume that's that's the problem that
y equals one if the probability that y
equals one is greater than 0.5 we're
just going to predict a one
okay yeah
he's like her
Sigma function
it's kind of just an arbitrary Choice
like if you want to get a number between
zero and one like I might have just
taken the average of
like so isn't our result heavily
dependent on the arbitrary choice of the
squashing function
yes
okay next question no I'm just joking
okay you say like hey I could have come
up with a different squashing function
that could make this thing that's real
valued and look make it look like a
probability and people have you know
sigmoid actually it's not old school but
there's other different squashing
functions that people now consider using
and some you know neural networks will
use different squashing functions other
than a sigmoid so you're right it was a
bit arbitrary but boy does it work
do we consider different excise or
whether Y is one or zero
um you know the the
meaning of X i's are going to stay the
same like X3 will always be whether or
not somebody likes Pulp Fiction in this
case
and the values of those X I's will
depend on the individual that you're
making the prediction for so if an
individual comes I will put all their
values of what they like for this movie
and then I will predict the why so I
wouldn't say that the X's depend on the
Y sorry the Y the X's depend on the Y's
rather I would say in our machine you
set the x's and we predict the Y's
and I'm afraid of throwing an orange
that far so please come after class and
grab your your Mandarin
okay
so
we've got inputs we've got weights AKA
parameters we have the weighted sum this
will be a number where every input has
been weighted we add them together get
the weighted sum at this point we've
calculated
you know this the sum of all the inputs
weighted by the particular weight added
together this is a number at this point
and then we squash that number and we
call the resulting of the squash a
probability we then make our prediction
and this is it this is the logistic
regression model AKA assumption
now a great question was where did you
get those parameters from the parameters
really matter
if I gave you different parameters you
would probably end up with different
predictions
similarly if you change the inputs if
you have the model if different people
show up and they have different tastes
like somebody doesn't like the Patriot
that can also change the output of this
model so this model is based on two
things the input of the individual
you're making the prediction for and the
parameters that have been set the
parameters are generally set for
everybody whereas each individual input
will have different what we call
features different X's
Okay so
putting that back into the language of
mathematics
logistic irrigation makes this
assumption the problem that y equals one
given all the features is going to be
sigmoid of Z
and in that sigmoid of Z we're going to
add up the weighted sum of all the
features
oh wait but there's this one extra
number
oh man let's go back
if a user likes these three movies I say
okay Independence Day we set that to
zero Patriot they like it so we set it
to one Pulp Fiction they like it so we
set it to one
what is going on with that x0
it doesn't correspond to a movie and
it's always set to one huh that's a bit
of a mystery
here's what that mystery is about
people realized this model does way
better when it's allowed to have a
particular parameter which can offset
the results of this uh equation so if
you have this weighted sum
people like to have a parameter that you
could just add to it
for Simplicity what we would do is we
would take the inputs the features and
we'd always set a zeroth value and we
would always set it to one
because if you set a zeroth value to 1
then your weighted sum just becomes
awaited sum where the first input will
be a one times by Theta zero
and 1 times Theta 0 is just going to
give you Theta zero it just allows you
to add in this intercept this is a
detail obviously it's not that critical
to the whole plot line
but this detail is going to be critical
when you actually have to go code this
it makes a big big difference in whether
or not this model works so the detail
here is yes we're going to make this
assumption and it's going to allow us to
calculate this number which is the
weighted sum of each input multiplied by
a feature we're going to squash that but
before we squash it we're going to add
in some other Theta
so there's a bunch of parameters in this
model and one of them just corresponds
to what we call the offset
to make this easy in your code you're
just going to take every input and
you're going to make add in a one before
it and then that one will be multiplied
by a Theta and that will make this the
offset okay I think that's a little bit
confusing so somebody could ask me a
question that would be wonderful
yes
would be true yeah it is a bit of a base
case you know another terminology for
exactly the same intuition is it kind of
biases the machine to either predicting
more people liking the movie or not
liking the movie like let's say your
output is a super popular movie
you might want to bias it so that you
predict that people like this movie more
often than not and so you can think of a
bit like a base case if everything else
is zero this is going to be influencing
the movie a lot and generally this can
either make you more likely to predict
one or less likely
come back and get your Mandarin after
class
it's been a while I'm not so confident
in my throwing long distance okay
so anyways
one thing I haven't told you this model
predicts the probability that y equals
one where is the model that predicts the
probability that y equals zero
you guys are far enough into probability
that you won't be surprised for me to
tell you you don't need another model if
you've got a model that predicts y
equals one and if you want to know
what's the probability that the
predictions you know that the output
class is a zero
you can just take advantage of the class
that probably that y equals zero given X
Plus probably the Y equals one given X
should be one so if you want the
probability that y equals zero
if that was your assumption for what's
the problem that y equals one probably y
equals zero is just going to be one
minus that
okay
moving and grooving and it all just
comes down to this this is the plot line
so far logistic regression gives us this
assumption that you can figure out the
probability that your output
being taken on the value one can be
calculated using this simple
mathematical or computer programmed
function the sigmoid of the weighted sum
of all of our inputs
sigmoid function looks like this and I
think some people started to Intuit this
but I want to be very clear
in this model
we're going to do the sigmoid of this
weighted sum so it's worth understanding
the sigmoid function and one thing
knowing about the sigmoid function is
its input's always a number
if that input is positive so the thing
that goes into the sigmoid is greater
than zero
then the output is going to be greater
than 0.5 so if Z is greater than zero
sigmoid of Z is greater than 0.5
if Sigma a z is interpreted as the
probability that y equals one
as soon as the input to the sigmoid gets
positive we'll predict that this is a 1.
as soon as the input to the sigmoid is
negative we're going to predict zero why
because if the input to the sigmoid the
thing that goes in here
is negative
then the result of the sigmoid will be
less than 0.5
and if the probability that y equals 1
is less than 0.5 we're going to be
predicting the other class label which
is zero
again questions comments concerns
as I said
this is how we're going to Define one
neuron in a neural network so it's worth
getting your head around
so if you have to wait some
um why do you even need to put into the
sigmoid function if you already know
whether or not it's going to be above or
below 0.5 such a good question so just
to say that back to you you're like hey
if I want to actually program this thing
up could I just get this weighted sum
and then just check if it's positive
forget the rest and if it's positive I
predict a 1 if it's negative I predicted
to zero
you're absolutely right for the
prediction
but when it comes to the other part
training this theory is going to be very
helpful because it will tell us how we
can update
um and you know even though you're right
you could also still use this mechanism
if you want to tell somebody not just a
one or a zero but you say this is a one
with probably 0.99 versus this is a one
with probability you know like 0.55 so
you might want to give more information
to the user where is this still useful
and also for the other Theory we're
going to need this
close
no one was hurt for people watching
online yes question
on each Theta times x i in some data
no I don't think that would give you the
same answer yeah if this thing the
sigmoid option to get really mathy is
this thing called non-linear so you
can't do a sigmoid of each Theta J times
x j and then add those up that would
give you a different number yeah good
question that turns out to be a really
really useful thing when you start
putting these together so what is now
annoying will later be useful question
so just zooming out a little bit it
seems like this method is for the most
part better than the base because it
because it makes an assumption that
doesn't sound this is crazy okay um is
that usually the case or does it really
depend on the situation and so how will
you know which one is better okay good
good good good good so the question is
hey now you've Bae has made this
assumption that we thought was crazy and
this feels better because the Assumption
isn't as crazy which one is better
it turns out in most cases where you're
either using logistic regression or
naive Bayes they're often pretty similar
and it turns out the decision is more
often defined by do you have things like
continuous inputs like when you start to
break out of binary values then one
tends to be more useful than the other
but right now if everything is binary
they look very similar
um
the naive Bayes assumption generally is
pretty good why wouldn't this be as good
like why wouldn't this just like blow
the pants off of naive Bayes it's still
making assumption like this isn't the
naive Bayes assumption but it's a pretty
simplistic assumptions like
probabilities in the world are nuanced
maybe there is much more complexity that
goes on to how y ends up being one and
it's not just this simple linear sum
thrown through a squashing function good
question yes
that's right
yeah
be able to be negative yeah
the weights can be negative
so the question is like how could you
get a negative value if these thetas are
negative then you can end up with a
negative value and the thetas absolutely
can be negative they're not constrained
in any way they could be anything from
negative Infinity to positive Infinity
what a good question let's actually
write that let's say our thetas
so Theta J is going to be an element of
any real number so it could be negative
Infinity to positive Infinity
okay
a little bit more exposition
not linear uh regression but linear
regression is doing a different thing
than classification right now we're
predicting ones and zeros
regression is generally what we call it
when you predict real numbers
classification is when you predict
something like you know Y is a one or Y
is a zero or why is a discrete value
linear regression is a name for an
algorithm that does regression I love it
naive Bayes is the algorithm for the
first classification that we've seen so
far and I love this question it's using
Bayes theorem it's making this really
naive assumption it's all beautifully
encapsulated in this name
foreign
the name of this algorithm is logistic
regression and I think it's an awesome
algorithm I think it is an awful name
why is an awful name first of all it's
not doing regression
it's doing classification you know
people called it regression because
technically it's regressing into the
real value that is the probability but I
think that's very confusing and instead
of using the term logistic logistic is
technically a parent name for a sigmoid
I would have called it Chris would have
called it the sigmoid classification
algorithm so I just want to point this
out that it's not a very good name
um it's uh really not doing regression
it is doing classification
but of course it's not that important
right now what is important is the final
mystery if you understand this model
you're most of the way there
you understand what logistic regression
is doing but now you need to peel back
to the next level of detail you need to
understand under the hood this next most
complicated mechanism which is where
does the intelligence come from and how
could you make your logistic regression
algorithm as smart as possible
what a mystery let's Dive In
the intelligence of a logistic
regression model
comes from its thetas
if you took a logistic regression model
and you gave me random thetas it would
be awful at making predictions I'd have
no reason to trust it but if you gave me
perfect thetas then maybe you could
start to do a good job the intelligence
lives in those thetas which begs the
question how are we going to get good
values of theta
and I mentioned this earlier but the
answer is we have a technique
for choosing parameters this is a
probabilistic model is producing a
probability
we can think about the likelihood of a
training data set
and we could ask the question which
values of these parameters would
maximize likelihood
that's a long way of saying we can just
use the parameter estimation techniques
we've learned so far we can take
training data and choose these
parameters based on training data
so we're going to do this we're going to
take training data and we're going to
try and learn them using this idea of
Maximum likelihood remember when we
first learned maximum likelihood I said
ah imagine we're trying to estimate the
parameters of a normal distribution and
I give you data points and you can try
and choose the parameters that maximize
the likelihood of those data points
we came up with a nice way of doing that
and that's exactly the idea we're going
to use for choosing the parameters
I'm going to do something a little bit
different though
today I'm going to focus on what's most
important for you for your problem set
which is what are the results of the
mathematics once you understand how you
could use those results then we're going
to drive them does that sound good so
we're going to start with the end point
we are going to use maximum likelihood
of estimation we're going to start with
the logistic assumption that for any
data in a database for example or a
training data set
the probability that the label takes on
the value 1 given the features is going
to be Sigma a Theta transpose X that's a
logistic regression assumption
and of course that also means that we
assume that the probability y equals
zero is just going to be 1 minus that
those are our assumptions
based on those assumptions we could call
this
uh some measure of the probability that
or this is the problem that y equals one
then we can take training data set and
we can figure out the likelihood based
on this assumption and once you get the
likelihood you can get the log
likelihood
and then what we're going to do is we're
going to be able to figure out how we
get the derivative of log likelihood now
you're going to later in class
understand the mathematics for how we
got this equation you'll understand the
mathematics for how we got this equation
but before we drive into any of that
mathematics you need to understand the
plot line
and the plot line is we're going to make
this assumption
then we're going to say Based on data I
can say How likely does that data look
under a particular set of parameters and
that's this function so if you gave me
any data set
and you gave me a particular setting of
parameters I could put those two things
together through that equation number
two
and it will score it you'll score your
parameters and say you know these
parameters are making the data look
really likely or these parameters look
pretty bad I can now tell the difference
between random parameters and smart
parameters
because smart parameters would make
training data look really really likely
again we'll understand this later I want
to make sure people understand the
plotline
this in itself is a scoring function it
doesn't tell you how to get good thetas
so that's where the derivative comes in
I make the Assumption I figure out a way
to score your parameters and I say you
want to choose good parameters pal you
give me the derivative and not just any
derivative I want the derivative of your
score with respect to every parameter
you might be changing
we'll be able to calculate that
numerically we'll come up with an
equation for it
and this equation is a thing we give to
our optimization algorithm at this point
we're happy to hand this over to
gradient ascent and we say choose the
values of theta that maximize this
scoring function and hey I know gradient
is sent you really want derivatives so
I'm going to give you some derivatives
so at this point we're willing ready to
give things over to optimization and
optimization will start changing values
of thetas it'll start coming up with
good values of thetas that'll eventually
make this score really high a question
though
is convex so that is a very very nice
property of our log likelihood function
okay plot line questions
you know
it's Justified yeah you know I mean just
to go back we're trying to choose these
parameters and the idea of convexity
would suggest that maybe there's really
easy ways to choose these parameters
um that didn't require going to gradient
descent and it also has other
implications if you end up with good
parameters
that are a local Maxima do you believe
that it could be a global Maxima and it
turns out all these things just end up
being true it is a very nice
maximization thing if you end up running
gradient Ascent if you get to a peak I
can guarantee you it's the global Peak
it's not just a peak it will be the top
of the mountain
and I'm just wondering like say for
example you have a problem where it
maximizes
so if it maximizes the score which we
use the likelihood function for if you
find some thetas that maximize the score
they'll be good and they'll be the best
status the the optimization algorithm
won't actually return you back bad
thetas
good good question
so at this point I've talked a little
bit about passing this equation off to
an algorithm
before we get into driving each of these
steps I want you to see the whole plot
line and the whole plot line really ends
with passing this off to an optimization
algorithm what does that look like
well Grady understand come on and play
our old friend you
remember gradient scent it says hey if
you want to end up with really awesome
parameters we're going to repeatedly
Hill Climb and by Hill Climb I mean
take your old parameter and then we're
going to figure out the derivative of
your score with respect to that
parameter
and we're going to multiply that by a
step size and add that and that will
become our new parameter so we're always
updating it if there's just one
parameter you can imagine this is like
taking small Steps either making the
parameter larger or maybe making the
parameter smaller if this is negative
step size is always positive
and then just slowly making your way
towards the ideal value of the parameter
if there is multiple parameters not a
problem we're just going to be each of
them is going to be making its progress
uh in sync
I think this is nice to show as
mathematics but I find this algorithm
much easier to look at sorry I'm going
to skip that a little bit and I'm going
to take this Focus where we say we want
to update each parameter we're going to
use
the idea of gradient ascent
and gradient descent requires a
derivative but I gave you what the
derivative was we didn't prove it but I
told you that this was the derivative
and I want to show you how we'll use it
if somebody gives you the derivative for
any particular Theta J so the derivative
of your score with respect to Theta J
you would plug this into here
and this is the equation that tells you
how you should change each of your Theta
J's on every step it says
as you're trying to get up this mountain
on every step update every Theta
take the old value
calculate this complicated thing you can
have python do that for you it will come
back as a number and that number when
you multiply by step size we're going to
use that to change the value the old
value will get Modified by whatever this
derivative is
and we'll put that in a whole Loop we'll
Loop this many times and the parameters
get better and better and better that's
the promise of hill climbing
but while it's nice to give you the
mathematics I think it's a little bit
nicer to give you pseudocode
the very simple idea of logistic
regression is this two-step algorithm
first you initialize your parameters and
then you optimize them
but that's too high level let's dive a
little bit deeper
when you're optimizing them
you're going to repeat many times taking
a step
to take a step you're going to calculate
all the gradients and then every single
Theta is going to be I is going to be
changed by the step size this n is not
the number of data points this is the
step size times the gradient of J we're
going to take all those gradients and
we're going to store them into numbers
the gradients will eventually become
numbers and we want to calculate those
actual numbers
a wild thing you know we think about
derivatives as being equations
but if you actually were to substitute
all of your data points and all of your
thetas this wouldn't just be an equation
be something that would turn into a
single number the derivative would
actually be a value a real value and
then we're going to take that real value
and store it into a variable and we're
going to use that to update Theta J
of course
this requires that we can calculate that
gradient and calculate the gradient you
know you're going to have to Loop for
every parameter and for every parameter
you're going to have to Loop over all
training examples and then you have to
actually update your gradient
and you know using the equation we gave
before this is a pretty reasonable thing
to do you could take you know for every
training example you could calculate
this term sum them all together that's
your gradient
at this point I don't want you to have
memorized this this will make much more
sense when you sit down to actually code
it and you'll look at this and be like
okay yes I need to get my gradients uh
we've got an equation for gradients I
can calculate the gradient each step
point and then I'm going to repeat many
times improving
but hopefully now I've shown you the
whole plot line
you know you've got
well actually okay maybe I'll stop here
we want to become smart by getting great
parameters that's where the intelligence
comes from
first we derive a log likelihood
function that's a score it tells you if
your parameters are good or bad then we
want to choose parameters that make that
score as large as possible so then we
get the derivative
we calculate the derivative and then we
use logistic or gradient Ascent to
choose the values of the parameters that
maximize our score and that uses hill
climbing AKA gradient Ascent which
requires you to be able to calculate
derivatives
so we needed to have figured out the
derivative which we did and then this
ends up being python when you run this
whole thing it will repeat many times
and at the end it will give you back
good values of thetas not just the
initial assignment to thetas
okay
that's it that's the next hardest thing
we'll talk about those derivations in a
second but
just to make sure we're following on the
plot line I want to show you this very
important chart
it's both meant to give you insight into
what I've been talking about but it's
also a great debugging technique
the promise of hill climbing is that you
might start out with bad thetas but over
time as you do this gradient Ascent your
thetas will get better and better and
better better particularly in terms of
the score that we call the log
likelihood or the likelihood
so when you start out you start out with
random values of thetas and your score
is going to be pretty low
but if you took one step of grading
Ascent it will end up moving all of your
thetas it will depend on the gradient
for each Theta so they could all move
differently
and once you get those gradients we're
going to take one step and they'll
change ever so slightly
we've now gone from the first step of
our algorithm to the next time through
the loop and an important thing that's
going to happen is because we changed
all these parameters
with respect to the derivative of the
score with respect to each parameter
we're guaranteed that the score should
go up
so the next time we calculate our score
it should be higher
it's not the final version of our
parameters we'd like to repeat this
gradient sent many steps so again we get
the derivative of the score with respect
to every parameter and they'll all
change once again so now they've changed
twice and we get to the next iteration
of our algorithm and again we're
guaranteed that these changes should
make the score go up so at this point
we've got
a third incarnation of our parameter
values and our score is starting to look
pretty good
gradient sent if you kept doing it your
score should just keep going up and up
and up
and that's what gradient a set is doing
is just giving you a way to change your
parameters so that your score goes up
and an important debugging idea you can
get from this is let's say your
algorithm is not working it could happen
you could go encode this up you could
run it and it could not be giving you
the results you wanted
one thing is you might have gotten your
derivatives wrong and if you get your
derivatives wrong it might not be the
case that likelihood is actually going
up
um over different iterations so this is
something I often used when I was
implementing logistic regression or
neural networks to make sure that I had
actually coded it up correctly
okay
and then finally I just want to take
this moment to remind you of this one
detail which was don't forget we still
have the intercept term remember we had
a Theta zero and that Theta 0 was going
to be added into our sum before we threw
it into the squashing function so before
we came up with the squash and function
we're going to add in the Theta zero
and don't forget that the way we
actually Implement that is by making x0
always equal to one if you make x0
always equal to one no matter who the
user is then that will be the same as
adding an intercept
okay
so classification we've already talked
about so I'm going to actually go quit
pretty quickly through that you know you
get the probability that y equals one if
that's greater than 0.5 you predict a
one otherwise you precake to zero for
the actual prediction we make we call
that y hat how cute it's like our guess
at Y and that hat is like making us look
a little silly so that you can tell that
we're a guess and we're not the actual
value anyways I don't think that's so
surprising at this point
so you get this value if it's greater
than 0.5 you predict a 1.
okay
but um you know just to be clear once
you've got good thetas you should be
able to take a new user
set their inputs to zero one one for
this particular user then you should be
able to do your forward pass get a value
of Z squash it get the probability if
that probability is greater than 0.5
then you predict a one
oh you guys worked really hard to follow
that plot line it's a pretty complicated
plot line there's a lot of moving pieces
but at this point hopefully you believe
me when I say okay you can make this
model okay we can score it
and if you can score it then you can
choose parameters that maximize that
score using gradient ascent but what I
haven't told you the missing part of the
story was where did those equations come
from
maybe you don't need to know you know if
you actually have to just code this up
for your homework you could skip this
final part of where those equations come
from you can just look up the slides get
those equations coded into python run it
get the right answer you know have your
good times go play with your friends
but I'm going to give you a reason for
why you should care about where those
equations come from
because logistic regression is just the
start of the story this is a good idea
that you can imagine is a seed and the
seed has blossomed in wonderful and
complicated ways so the extent that you
can understand the seed is the extent to
which you could understand deep learning
so we should really know all the
different parts especially if you want
to either be the ones to make this
flourish or as you guys know AI is going
to require us to understand it it's
having big impacts on society
and we need to really really get our
heads around what these powerful tools
are doing for both those reasons we
really want to know how this black box
is going to be working so you guys ready
for jumping into this math
okay so I gave you these equations I
said this is our assumption based on the
Assumption you can get that this is the
score and then we can derive score with
respect to each parameter but I didn't
tell you step by step how you get these
two values so let's do it
how do we get that log likelihood
function
as you recall
a very funny thing happened when we
wanted to do mle on a Bernoulli when we
wanted to do Emiliano Bernoulli the
first step is you've got training data
that'll be a bunch of zeros and ones can
you write How likely that training data
looks
based on the parameters in the case of a
Bernoulli there's only one parameter
that's the probability parameter P do
you remember Bernoulli it's either one
or zero and it's one with probability p
if you're doing mle to choose a
Bernoulli your your job was to choose a
p
and the mle step-by-step formula the
first phase of mle says write down how
write down a likelihood function which
often would require you to write down
the probability Mass function
a Bernoulli probably Mass function looks
like this
but we have this issue
that the Bernoulli probably Mass
function which says you know the
probability of a one should be whatever
your parameter p is the probability of Z
should be one minus that P this really
simple thing
is not drivable
those bar charts weren't derivable so
even though the Bernoulli is a simple
concept and has a simple probability
Mass function we couldn't write a
likelihood function for Bernoulli's that
was drivable
so instead we did this super cheeky
thing where we came up with a derivable
version of this bar chart that derivable
version of this bar chart
looks like this
it takes your parameter and raises it to
Y remember for Bernoulli y can only be
zero one
and then it multiplies it by this other
term which is 1 minus the parameter
raised to the power of 1 minus y
insanity
but in sanity that we need to understand
this is what people use in logistic
regression and deep learning and Beyond
for likelihoods of a Bernoulli because
this is going to be drivable this is
equivalent to the bar chart when y
equals zero or one and let's just do one
example of that to remind ourselves
let's take this equation and plug in 1
for y
if you plug in 1 for y you get P to the
power of one everybody what's P to the
power one
oh okay good so we have P that's good
multiplied by this other scary term ooh
well if y was 1 what's 1 minus y
and what's whatever raised to the power
of zero okay so we have P times one
which gives us uh yay okay so this is
really nice when you put in a one for y
it gives you back p
so if you put in a one for y you get
back p and it turns out if you put in a
zero for Y into this crazy equation
you'll just get back 1 minus P because a
really really complicated way of writing
that bar chart but we needed to do this
because it made it derivable
recalling that the first step of mle
means take this assumption and now
imagine you had a training data set and
write How likely does that training data
set look in the face of the current
setting of parameters score the
parameters by coming with a likelihood
function
imagine that
you just had one thing in your training
data point
the way we could score it is we could
use the Bernoulli we could say hey take
your single training data point
and if you put that X the inputs of the
train data point if you did transpose of
theta and put it through a sigmoid this
whole thing here
that is the probability that y equals
one it's the parameter P of Y which is a
Bernoulli
you know this thing here that's the P of
your Bernoulli the whole thing that
comes out of logistic regression
equation is the probability that y
equals one
and if we use that continuous derivable
version of a Bernoulli probably Mass
function says you know the likelihood
that y takes on its value which could be
a zero or one for a data point in your
data set given the inputs
for that single data point is going to
be P to the power of either the one or
zero that is y times 1 minus P to the
power of 1 minus the one or zero that is
y
so to be clear your data point would
have an X and the X could be something
like
hey remember x0
is always a one always a one but maybe
there's three other features and they
represent whether people like the
different movies it could be a zero zero
one
and in this case Y is going to be a
number zero or one
and Theta
it's going to be a list which could be
like you know negative seven two zero
three
which will be the ways that you weight X
before you squash it and get the
probability that y equals one
and we're going to score this
combination
you have your data you have your
training data which at this point is
hilariously just one how funny would be
to train a whole machine learning
algorithm with one data point now we
want a lot of data points why am I
starting with one because the math is
easier so let's start with one
so if you have one data point and you
have you want to score this Theta
you would calculate the probability that
y equals one based on these thetas so
you'd take this Theta transpose it with
X that gets your weighted sum squash it
and that squash will give you the
probability that y equals one
and if you put that into this equation
for y we're going to substitute one
because that's what the data point says
and that means we're going to ignore
this whole thing and we'll just be left
with this term
so it'll just be the probability that y
equals 1. so if our data point had a one
this likelihood function will just
return you back the number which is the
probability your algorithm said that the
data point would be one
take a moment and talk to the person
next to you and see if you can ask a
question about why that's true because I
do want to stop here this seems like if
you can follow this the rest will be
just math so talk to the person next to
you see if you can come up with a
question what's confusing about this or
what could I understand more deeply uh
take a minute and a half just to have a
chat
foreign
okay what are we doing here we want to
choose good thetas mle tells us how but
the first thing you have to do with LMU
is you have to come up with a scoring
function say how good do my thetas look
like based on some real training data we
thought about this in the case where you
have just a single data point and my
claim for you is if you have just a
single data point you can calculate this
equation which will return you back a
single number which will be the score of
how good your thetas are for that single
data point but it's a very confusing
thing there's a lot going on here you
have logistic regression you have
interpreting the output as a probability
of a Bernoulli we have the continuous
drivable probability Mass function of
the Bernoulli and all three of those
things are happening at the same time
it's just so much that we should ask
some good questions
any questions come up
yes the inputs that aren't binary
good question so the question is if we
have inputs that are not binary how will
this get transformed I have good news
for you if your inputs are non-binary
you could use the exact same thing it's
just the X's will happen to be not zeros
in ones
if the output happens to be non-binary
becomes much more complicated because
we're going to be interpreting the
output of this logistic regression as a
probability of a Bernoulli and so if you
can have your why take on non-burn newly
values it's going to not work so inputs
can change to be anything but output
we're going to say has to be zero and
once good questions and I owe you
mandarins I am going to keep aside the
three mandarins that I owe
yes
sorry wait actually
for naive Bayes
um we were we were able to do joint
distribution doing probabilities of like
multiple random variables are we going
to see an example of this here or do we
just assume the whys of the factory so
in naive Bayes we could have X be a
vector
and here you can also have X be a vector
in both cases X can have lots of
features
um and in both cases the thing you're
predicting is always just a zero or a
one so both of them are going to have
the exact same format X can be large y
will be either single zero one and this
is a little bit hard to see but my X is
bolded just to try and show that it
could be a whole list you know my X can
be a whole list of numbers whereas my y
will either be a zero one which is the
exact same format as naive Bayes you are
right that in naive Bayes there's much
more interpretal way of talking about
the joint likelihood of X and Y whereas
this one's not trying to do a joint it's
just time to talk about the probability
of Y given X so an ivase is trying to do
something a little more complicated
that's why he has to make his assumption
good good question
yes
why do we need to be concerned about
multi-collinearity
why don't you need to be concerned about
it well the idea being gradient Ascent
will choose good thetas even if things
are collinear or not collinear it will
still be able to just optimize let's
talk about that after class
okay yes so
basically saying that the the output of
our machine learning is like is it
removing and it's got some p-value and
we're basically assuming what p is if I
like to say in our case we're saying
it's signal function but you could use
something else yeah that's exactly it
it's just saying okay I'm assuming this
Y is a Bernoulli I need a little
mechanism to get the probability of it
being one I've got logistic regression
you could have made a different machine
but logistical machine is the machine
that we chose and that's what we've got
and because that's what we've got
because this is really a Bernoulli we
can just write a likelihood function
no it's squashes nicely there's not a
deeper reason it's a squashing function
think of it being practical uh not being
driven by Deep Neuroscience or something
like that yes question
um the probability is the principles of
theta multi you know
multiplied with x
yeah pass through the sigmoid and so
that whole thing is to the power y right
yes this is a probability this is the
parameter P of our Bernoulli
and why do the thetas change that's one
thing that I've had trouble
understanding in the previous explosion
so with e23 we want the thetas to change
so we first thing we're just going to
come up with the scoring function but
then we're going to use the scoring
function to change our thetas and we
want to change this thetas to make the
scoring function go as large as possible
so you can think about the score the
thetas are movables they're things that
we can move and your job is to move them
and move them in a good direction so
that's why they change is because it
will end up making this thing smarter
but we still need to derive this in
order to figure out exactly how we
should make them change
so your first claim though I think was
very helpful I think that's something I
really want to highlight this whole
thing we could have just called the P to
our parameter and in fact
you will sometimes see people give this
whole thing a different symbol to
represent it because it's just used so
much and and this equation would have
been a lot easier if we said something
like we call this P hat
and we just started using p hat symbol
anytime you saw this it would make this
maybe a little bit more readable and
some people do do that
okay you guys rock those are very good
questions
the great thing about likelihood is that
if you assume all your data points are
IID so each data Point's independent of
other data points different from the
naive Bayes assumption that's assuming
the features are independent if you
assume the data points are independent
which is very reasonable
then the likelihood of more than one
point is just going to be the product
over many many points of the exact same
function that we had here so take that
and just put it through a loop of
multiplication
so it says for every data point in my
data set we're going to calculate its
likelihood so this was the likelihood of
one data point and we want the data
points the product of the likelihood of
every data point in our data set
so then we can just substitute in here
notice that if y was always one we
wouldn't need this term
but for some of our data points y will
be one and for other data points y will
be zero and don't forget that this is
just picking out either P or 1 minus p
okay
and that's a scoring function yes
yes exactly and particularly it's which
data point okay so here this is saying
oops
pen this is not an exponent it's just
saying the ith data point and this is
the same notation that they use in 221
uh and 229 so I did want to start using
that notation here to set you guys up if
you ever take those classes but you
don't have to but they're kind of fun
I digress so yeah this is saying your
data point has n values and we're going
to loop I being the index of the curtain
data point you're on and we're going to
calculate this for the current data
point this was one data point but in the
next data point this could be like
superscript zero or superscript 5 let's
say
and then the next data point maybe you
know you have different inputs and a
different y
now I skipped ahead to this this is a
scoring function it would have been just
fine but if you try and program this for
a large data set you'll have underflow
problems so instead of just using the
scoring function we're going to use the
log of it because log is monotonic
if this is a good scoring function the
log of it will also be a good scoring
function so let's use the log
okay so at this point I've given you the
mathematics for the first equation that
you saw
which was this is the scoring function
for how good your parameters are
and we're not there yet the last thing
we need to do is be able to say okay
that's a scoring function
give me a way to make my parameters
better
which means we need a gradient
we have to be able to drive that scoring
function that thing that can take a
Theta and say this is good or bad and we
want the derivative of that score with
respect to each parameter
okay we're going to do something Brave
before we do it though know this thing
about sigmoids
sigmoids are not just a squashing
function they're a squashing function
with the most beautiful derivative
if you want to know the derivative of a
sigmoid
it is equal to the sigmoid itself times
1 minus the sigmoid if you notice the
sigmoid function has this natural base e
and as you know natural base e is the
very special number where if you had to
take its derivative of e to the power of
X it has that nice property of not
changing
for similar reasons because sigmoid has
the e natural base in it its derivative
ends up being very very nice it says
gorgeous
that is another reason we use sigmoids
by the way it's a squashing function
with a beautiful easy derivative
okay
whoo
you now have
a likelihood oh before we do that I just
want to show you guys what this could
look like using the sigmoids derivative
before we do any hard derivatives or
hard likelihood derivatives so this is
an aside welcome to my little aside I
just told you sigmoid has a beautiful
derivative that's in the top right and I
want us to practice using the sigmoids
derivative
and particularly I want us to calculate
the derivative of this expression
with respect to one of the thetas just
as practice just as warm up
what you should do is you should use
chain rule you should say this is a
composition of doing step one this is
step one and then once you do step two
you step two is to put this through the
sigmoid function if you have a two-step
process it's a good candidate for
something you can break apart using the
chain rule particularly I'm going to say
that Z is going to be equal to
Theta transpose X you know Z is just the
input to the sigmoid and so this is
going to be the same as the derivative
of sigmoid Z with respect to Z and the
derivative of Z with respect to Theta J
as I said you should practice chain rule
you should make sure you know it watch
the Khan Academy and make sure you can
follow exactly this example because this
is the application that is most
important of chain rule
now
if you want to plug and chug
this derivative of sigmoid Z with
respect to Z is just going to be Sigma
of Z times 1 minus Sigma of Z so sigmoid
of Z
times 1 minus sigmoid of Z remember um Z
is just Theta transpose X so sigmoid of
Z is that and 1 minus Sigma of Z is that
so that is just that first expression
their derivative sigmoid of Z with
respect to C is just sigmoid Z times 1
minus sigmoid Z done
and then we need this expression
what's the derivative of Z with respect
to a particular Theta J
and I'll tell you the answer right now
but let's understand why
if you're deriving this expression with
respect to a particular Theta let's say
you're deriving this
so the derivative of theta transpose x
with respect to Theta 5.
recall what this is you know it's Theta
0 times x 0 plus Theta 1 times X1 plus
Theta 2 times X2 where does Theta 5 show
up
only times X5 the only part of this term
where Theta 5 shows up is when it's
multiplied by X5 that's the only place
so if you derive this whole thing with
respect to Theta 5 it would be the same
as deriving
Theta 5 times X5 with respect to Theta
5.
and if you're driving this simple
multiplication with respect to Theta 5
what is it
oh you guys said it so timidly say it
loud I want to hear people in recording
want to hear your voices
yeah that's just X5 more generally
if you're driving with respect to Theta
J it will be x j so if J was 5 it would
be X5 if J was 3 it would be X3
Okay so
a simpler way of writing the exact same
thing would be is you could have
declared this to be y hat and this is
just you know
sigmoid of Z times one minus Z times x j
which is the same as this expression
times 1 minus this expression times x j
this is just a really cleaner way of
writing what we derived before
where y hat is equal to this sigmoid of
Z
so Sigma of Z times 1 minus Sigma a of Z
times x j that is the derivative
okay we don't have time for pedagogical
pause we took the question before
are you guys ready
this is Stanford we can do this
is the thing that I want you to drive in
terms of theta J
um okay just go and derive it
[Music]
we can do this
here are a couple Pro tips
this is going to be the derivative of a
sum of the logs right
so this is the thing we're driving in
it's got a big sum here let's start by
just doing the derivative of one of
these inner things because the
derivative sum is just the sum of
derivatives so if you can do the
derivative of the inner part your life
will become really easy the derivative
of sums is the sum of derivatives just
tell me the derivative of this inner
part so then my question becomes a
little bit easier can you derive this
and particularly
anytime I see
a sigmoid of theta transpose X every
time I see this thing I'm going to call
it y hat because that notation makes
things so much easier to read
and if you call that y hat then this is
going to be just derive this with
respect to a Theta J you're like where
are all my thetas oh don't forget the
thetas are actually in the y-hats
because the y-hats are actually this
expression so they're still there but
that's the derivative we're trying to do
okay
now derive this inner thing with respect
to Theta J
where I'm using this shorthand
for y hat which is sigmoid of theta
transpose X
idea of chain rule is this
there are no thetas here all the thetas
are hidden in these y hats because the
y-hats are my shorthand for Sigma to
Theta transpose X
you should not try and do this
derivative straight instead you should
use chain rule you should say all of my
thetas are in y hat so I should derive
that whole expression with respect to Y
hat
and then I should derive y hat with
respect to the Theta J chain rule is
decomposition for derivatives it allows
you to take a big derivative and do it
in Parts it says okay just drive things
with respect to Y hat then y hat with
respect to Theta J do those separately
and multiply them
so
let's start out with what is the
derivative of y hat with respect to
Theta J
I have good news for you if y hat is
this expression
driving it with respect to Theta J is
the thing we did in our warm-up we
actually figured this out it was sigmoid
of theta trans plus x times 1 minus
Sigma of theta transpose x times x j and
I just wrote the exact same thing here
don't forget the Y hat was my new
shorthand for writing sigmoid of theta
transpose J hey we're halfway there now
all you have to do is derive that
expression with respect to Y hat
and remember you're using Y hat as a
variable you at this point you can
forget that y hat equals this at all
and just say what is the derivative of
this expression with respect to some
variable called y hat
well
if you take this first term what's the
derivative of y log y hat with respect
to Y hat
well this doesn't have y hat so it'll
just come as a term and log of Y hat
drive with respect to Y hat is just one
over y hat and same thing here log of 1
minus y hat will just become 1 over 1
minus y hat but because there's a you
know a little thing going on inside the
log you have to drive that with respect
to Y hat and you get a negative sign
so this positive became a negative sign
and this term just came out here this
whole derivative becomes this term which
is not so bad
and we're done we just did this crazy
hard derivative it turns out by using
chain Rule and breaking into the
derivative of loss with respect to Y hat
derivative y hat with respect to Theta
it becomes not so bad
you could simplify this a little bit if
you actually did the math but that's not
as important as knowing how to do the
derivatives
now if you were to do this
um as the sum you know we skip this part
we just did the derivative of the inside
but this will just become the sum of
each of those derivatives so we did this
derivative and then you're just going to
sum that over for all your data points
which leaves us at
how you get the derivative of your
scoring function with respect to each of
the thetas
which brings us to the end of our story
you guys know logistic regression you
guys under
understood you guys understand how we
score it and now you understand how you
could drive the score with respect to
each Theta J which you can then put into
gradient Ascent wow you work so hard
and I have a treat for you come back in
Wednesday and I will tell you how this
becomes the blossom that is deep
learning we will understand deep
learning and the extent that we
understand logistic regression have a
fantastic day get started early on
problems at six I appreciate you guys so
much come back on Wednesday cheers cs109